this connect is three different stories
that were pulled right out of the
headlines and dramatized and then
threaded together you know to create an
emotional thriller it's about the way
that technology it's all these screens
in our lives can can bring us closer and
then can also keep us farther apart from
from each other and the movie is not
just about technology it's also about
the way in which we communicate with
each other about how people talk to each
other and that's was very interesting to
me and very important to me it explores
the way in which we communicate and to
me ultimately the movie is much more
about the power of human communication
then about technology technology is
neither good nor bad it is a reflection
of us you know technology puts puts
makes bombs and it and it can you know
put put us on Mars I've met people who
are very distractible people who are
always on their phones they were
distractible people to begin with and
I've met wonderfully calm and wise
people who keep their phones in their
pockets and especially during dinner
those were calm and centered people so I
don't think technology makes us do
anything I think it's our personalities
that are you know expressed through all
these devices that we have and that's
one of the things the the film tries to
explore we've never been able to be as
close with with all these people
everywhere in our lives on different
continents before as we have now and
that's very exciting but when you are
connected to thousands of people it's
it's hard to find time for the people
that you really want to connect with you
know so that's just one of the ways in
which the duality of Technology affects
you know our attention span I mean we've
never been in the history of mankind
connected with so many people we've
never been asked to focus on so many
different things until this time right
now
now we are you know it is so easy to
talk to to 300 people in a day so it's
an exciting time I think for us for us
human
but with it comes that was Samantha's
phone that just went off and gave us a
little interlude it was but I think it's
really exciting you know I love
technology I'm excited that I was alive
when the internet exploded this is not
an anti-technology movie at all but it's
asking questions that I think everyone
is asking every day how much time do you
spend on the Internet or how much time
you spend on your phone how much time
you spend connected with those hundred
people as opposed to those hundred
people you know who do you really give
your time and your attention to these
are decisions we have to make now every
day whereas you know 10 20 years ago we
didn't have to make those decisions you
know we just sort of hung out with
whoever was in front of us